Welcome to the popular bar Omae 2 is more useful than Omae. Welcome to the
station, which is definitely not for the masses. New tricks.
The
concept was to handle things that seemed to be crushed in a new way, and
it prospered all at once. It's a victory for a change of thinking. It's
too different.
I didn't think that
heritage is a part-time job car.
I don't want to work even if I
die.
I pinched it, but
none
, if you want me to tell
you, can you say bad things to the guys around me?
Let's
go home Azusa-sama
, but if you can get the information, I'd like to order an additional Ei-chan, but do
n't talk with a bucket-old
man.  Right under the stakes Ah,
you like horses, water isn't enough
Hey, laugh a little, queen
boo boo, scorned like a good kid, yeah yeah yeah
ni
is August 1 year
ae  Do you want to be delicious? It ’s
delicious.
After that, you ’re the same human beings.